(Robert): Aerys Targaryen was the last
of his name to sit on the Iron Throne.
Known far and wide as the Mad King,
his was a reign of instability and terror.
The Seven Kingdoms are
well rid of him and his kind.
Oh, he may have appeared to be
a capable ruler at first,
but that was due in no small part
to his councilors,
led by the Hand of the King,
Tywin Lannister.
There may have been years of peace
and prosperity during Aerys' reign,
but it was Tywin who was really
running the country,
as Aerys spiraled further
and further into insanity.
The dragon spawn were famous
for losing their minds.
It was the price they paid for centuries
of keeping the bloodlines pure.
And Aerys more than happily continued
the noble sister-fucking tradition
of his forefathers.
As the years passed, Aerys' behavior
became increasingly erratic.
He cut himself so often on his Iron Throne,
many referred to him as King Scab,
though never to his face.
It was rumored he had developed
an obsession with wildfire,
and was known
to inflict horrific punishments
on those he considered enemies,
including burning them alive.
As his paranoia and blood-lust grew,
he had a bitter falling-out with Lord Tywin
who had served the Crown
faithfully for 20 years.
At least Tywin was able to leave the job
with his life and fortunes intact.
Subsequent Hands of King Aerys
weren't so fortunate.
Then the Targaryens went too far.
The Crown Prince Rhaegar
abducted Lyanna Stark,
daughter of Rickard Stark,
the Lord of Winterfell.
She was my betrothed. She was my beloved.
Beautiful and spirited woman.
And I loved her more than life itself.
Rhaegar went south with Lyanna,
hiding her away in Dome.
What harm he inflicted on the poor girl,
the gods only know.
Brandon Stark, Lyanna's eldest brother,
was outraged.
He rode to King's Landing
to confront the king
and demand his sister's safe return.
Instead, Aerys had him executed.
His father, Rickard Stark, as well.
There wasn't much left
to discuss after that.
Aerys feared their loved ones
would seek revenge for what he did.
He was right to be afraid.
Aerys wasted no time in calling
for the heads of Brandon's younger brother,
my friend Eddard Stark,
and my head, too, of course.
I'm sorry he didn't come
looking for it himself.
Alongside Jon Arryn of the Vale -
the man who fostered
Ned and I as children -
Baratheons, Starks and Tullys
all called their banners.
Once our rebellion began,
the Mad King's days were numbered.